so we we're so glad that we can
welcome jacasimir professor
jambo
so his name is actually i love the name
tj
busal and i think you'll get to hear
more perhaps about the only one who
called me like that well that's your
name on twitter that is um that's his
handle on twitter it's tj bosal and
which has which is quite loaded in
symbolism yes
that's why i love it
um so
so i can say that you know the entire
semester
all of our discussions have prepared us
for his visit in many ways um
because the topic of this class um
is um
basically about
the use
or the misuse of language in the way we
create our identity or the way we
we misidentify ourselves these are the
our compatriots because obviously the
world and as we saw actually through
each of them you get to hear more is
that growing up we are socializing to
certain beliefs
about language that can either
give us power or can
this remove power from us you see and
then we've discussed various ways in
which we can regain that power we can
keep that power alive and that's what
your work is all about
in the particular case of of haiti so
so we've read um your parts of your book
comes really chapter 8 on the beauty and
the power of the suffering people of
haiti
where you show so clearly
the key importance of language as you
call it as a living archive because when
you write about
people who've been oppressed what
everything's excluded where do you get
your archives because they didn't write
the history he's written by the
europeans by the winners so and one way
to recover that history is through
language and in the in the case of 80s
through creole right and that's one of
the main
aspects of john's work that i felt
extremely important for me
um and for me personally why
is so important um in terms of my own
liberation is because this is what i
grew up with so i grew up with this um
with this textbook so this is my history
textbook this is where i learned
the history of my country um
and and
and it's actually it's quite amazing to
think of it you know i think of the
concept that you brought up yesterday on
monday of deformation you know the point
of
colonized people either in the caribbean
or palestine being deformed through
historical factors
is that haiti is a proud independent
country so in the caribbean you know
people know about haiti like there are
songs written about haiti but hates
struggles for independence
yet little haitians like myself will
learn history from a book
that's um
that receive
the imprimatur the approval of what if
you read here this is the premature of
the catholic church
so the catholic church is institution
that approves
the version of history
that teachers teach us
about our old history and then the part
that's very striking um is the is the
pre preface which i put here because
it's so striking and i'm just going to
read
um the the bottom part of it so so here
it says that
um the mean people will teach you how to
detest
evil
um and how to honor virtue and the good
people who teach you will teach you are
to honor virtue and then our heroes will
teach you
um patriotic pride and the price of
liberty
um and we have to admire the efforts of
a las casas
the value of souls um for eternity
now
does anyone know about las casas
so tell me marilyn what do you know
about lascaux um i know he mostly said
like in the dominican side of the island
um he was basically like a priest kinda
but he was also like a history first in
a historian he was an author and he kept
writing up like every single thing he
was very much you know pro-indigenous
and he tries to defend them but just
basically you know recording history yes
actually that's a good point so las
casas he was very much pro-indigenous
and he was so pro-indigenous that what
what he did when he noticed that the
indigenous people were dying off
they were you know dying of yellow fever
or various abuses of genocide he thought
that the best way to save the the the
so-called indians is to bring in the
africans because he is he has his theory
that
black people
are
in fact he invented the notion well they
in the nation of blackness that blacks
are this thin for slavery therefore
let's bring this the
the africans in
to save the indigenous people he said
that that was a deal he made with with
the powers of europe so he was a major
promoter of the slave trade and this is
who we're being asked you know in in the
name of virtue to honor and to adore las
casas and and the others will thank you
they are missionaries basically you see
do you see any name of a haitian freedom
fighter there is no deciline here there
is no two c here there is no bookman
here
you see and this is what we have to
adore and then it says at the end
love this little book and be docile
so that's a history book now this is a
literature book a literature book
written by
a french
brother called
catholic brother called
rafael birhou a haitian linguist asian
linguist called trebel pompilus
well-known haitian linguist
and one of the favorite
authors
of in this book is uh karl brown who
wrote um this is something that the
priest would have us recite by heart
that
the the question of creole is ridiculous
what
development can he expect from its
creole creole will nev will be nothing
but a patois there is nothing to do
about this and then it goes on to say
parents never speak create your children
french is a habit that you have to
develop therefore
be pitiless in correcting your children
when they when they use cruel isms
you see
so
do you imagine a country where most
parents speak only creole that book asks
that parents never speak cruel to your
children can you imagine so it means
really that in order to follow this they
wouldn't just they would never speak
with children they have to
this is
so this is just as a background to tell
you why
and actually this is more actually the
same so this is um
my report card from senior gonzaga
actually you went where you actually
goes
so so actually so we shared that same
school so jean casimir
um i went to go like maybe 50 years
apart maybe i don't know
no no yes but i spent three years in san
diego okay okay so do you remember these
report cards you know they had colors
they didn't have oh yeah yeah they were
color coded they were let me try you
remember yes yes thank for very well oh
green i don't remember the color but it
was color coded so this was you know i
was a good student right so yeah
very well but this is the cost of the of
this trivia you have to adhere to these
directives you know so basically
students cannot have to be present um
you cannot bring weapons to class you
know
nice
forbidden you cannot loiter and then
rule number four the use of cruel is
prohibited
you see that so to me
you better not be clear so so now to
move on to
today um
so that's why i've been so so happy
right to bring in
and and here i want to give thanks to
the history
unit i want to give thanks to mit global
languages and also global friends um
he's also
sponsoring um john's visit and mit haiti
also is sponsoring john's visit and so
if i gave this talk on monday uh vivian
was there and it was an amazing really
an amazing talk which you might get to
hear more about um today but really what
jean is teaching us to do is to re-read
nation history not from the perspective
of the las casas the bhutan the eu the
brothers of the criminal instruction
he's asking us to reread ancient history
from the perspective of the
formerly colonized from that of the
captives
and and he's doing
and john is i like to say that john is
the one of the rare very rare
intellectuals who've been producing
texts in creole for
actually when was the first the first
text you produced in creole in on
history sociology when was that i'm
going to tell you
in the 70s you see in the journal cell
okay the father's right and
i don't remember that i have it at home
actually i found it no yeah so that
that's avant-garde that's really forward
thinking that in the 70s that was before
the famous reform there now oh yes
indeed you know it was before that we
have this reform in 82 that basically
say look you know the schools are
feeling asian children we have to use
creole as a tool of instruction and
before that jean was producing
text in creole on history and and we're
very pleased that john has so happily
agreed to translate some of his work in
career that we're putting on platform
mit 80 and so so actually we spent time
today discussing the next article that
will go which is on that very topic d
colonial versus colonial so that's why i
i feel really honored and we should all
be pleased to have shane with us today
so this is actually
and and i love this talk this um
it says
technology
in the in the laku the lakku is this
communal unit where haitians live that's
where we get we get a sovereignty
triggers
protests the kind of protesters that can
actually log down the country pay luck
is the term that's used in haiti when
you when it's a protest you you
basically
shut down the country out of protest and
in that croquette what john does which
is actually very relevant to our work
here and i can think of what's the what
gabby is doing for for a project is how
how to use technology
to be able to
move social change forward and and in
this coquette it talks about how
haitians even very poor haitians or very
important stations i should say
manage to use the phones whatsapp to be
able to create protests so in a way
that's a bit what we're doing to using
technology
like in the in the platform to push
forward the clear movement um and i
wanted to because john
used to work for united nations um how
many years did you spend uh working for
that i spent 15 years working there but
i was the representative of haiti at
unesco you were yes but i never went i i
resigned before going okay okay this is
great this is great john because i'm
going to show you what your successor is
doing now yes dominic gp
i call it
spam
why i want to show you this is to show
you the you know the power of a germany
and how a germany even affects science
because unesco
is the unit for education science and
culture
at the u.n and unesco's basic mission is
to promote linguistic diversity and
equity and human rights
yet in unesco's recent survey
for the atlas of languages look at this
table here they ask each country to
check um
a box here
based on your language and
so you have the choices
you speak at isolate link
you speak a language long you speak a
mixed language you speak a korean
language you speak speaking language so
there is a concept of language without
any adjective that's the unmark category
and then if you speak a creole then you
basically in a separate category and
when you look at the guide for the atlas
it tells you that
a cruel language is not on the par with
language why because it comes from a
pigeon that's the argument that because
creoles come from pigeons therefore they
don't belong to that category you see
and something which actually has loads
of evidence
data analysis against that
so i want to close by showing
successor after many years
at the so this happened in early april
so basically what she did was it was
amazing she challenged unesco's
categorization
of queer languages and let's just listen
to this and then
it's going to be your turn to
tell us more about
your work in this in this class
let's play this
so um actually so as we speak as we
speak i'm i'm looking forward to hearing
from
the ambassador gp
about how unesco a class is responding
because at first they say well our
experts tell us this is what creels are
you know we have to address our experts
but he's been pushing back
which is
tell us which is
exactly that's okay so but now actually
in the past couple of days there's been
some back and forth and i'm hoping maybe
before the meeting ends that that's in
fact i just sent them a picture of this
now to remind us that you know we're
here waiting for
for some result here of what she's doing
okay so
i think i think that should give enough
context here to why you know
this this person that we have here is so
so important both for me personally but
also for
for us you know fighting for
for emancipation really um so
so let's go around the room and um and
introduce ourselves um to professor
jacasimir
[Laughter]
hi i'm josiah
actually it's great
i think we're told that with the
minecraft with the mask it might be a
bit so as you speak if you could just
remove it and put it back
okay but just when you speak and you can
put it back afterwards yes hi
i'm from jamaica and that's the reason
why i'm so interested in taking this
class
my project is on the role economics can
play informing like
like the opinions on different languages
so usually tends to like the rich tend
to
determine like what language is
acceptable in society and so i'm
researching that
all right
any question for jasara
no i mean the only question i can say
is that
well i don't know if this is a
compliment for you but as far as i'm
concerned jamaican jamaica and haiti are
so similar they look like
twins you know
and i said the only difference is that
jamaica was under the british who were
coming up
the empire and we were with the french
going down so we got independent
the only difference is they not us
no and what is important for jamaica and
for myself also
is that we have a language
now i had a jamaican professor friend of
my good friend of mine historian he says
when i am in jamaica people speaking
jamaican i don't understand
he was genuinely
a
anglophone he can't speak jamaican quill
and i will give i could give you endless
example
now of
this cruel
no
giving the note of a different country
no and jamaica certainly the country
where you have
the free village system established and
acknowledged by the
by the empire that's quite important
what i call counter plantation system
so my name is rachel robinson i'm also
jamaican oh oh the master
um
and so i was interested in taking this
class because i've never really had the
opportunity to take a class like this
about like caribbean identities and like
real languages and i didn't really know
like too much about it and i thought
this would be such a great space to
learn more about it um
throughout like my life i guess i would
say i've had like some struggles with my
jamaican identity and like knowing my
history my culture and
like really claiming it as my own given
like that i wasn't born there and like i
just i just don't know as much um
so this class has helped me a lot in
growth and like really claiming it and
want getting more excited to like learn
more to reach out to like my parents my
grandparents my family members and
things like that so um one of the
projects i did in this class was just
like about our identities and that i
kind of talked about like my struggle
and the this was earlier on so
i hadn't made as much growth i think as
i have now
um but i just talked about like
different things that i've struggled
with and ways that i want to
um like try to fix that and grow and
yeah that was probably like my favorite
thing that i've like done because it
just was so almost healing to kind of
talk about myself and i put like a lot
of pictures of my family and like that
was just really nice to see yeah
yes i don't have much to add except that
for instance
the production of music in jamaica and
in the cabin
i don't have to add i just mentioned
that and you can imagine the rest to
tell you the beauty of the sovereign
people because it's not music from the
high classes
you know i mean that make jamaica that
put jamaica on the map
hello i'm ianna ferguson i'm from san
francisco grenadines um i took this
class because i grew up in saint vincent
so i've always had like knowledge of
caribbean history from a caribbean
person's perspective so i was interested
to see how it would look from
i guess americans perspective in this
class and so
that's why i took the class
my main project in the class is
examining the linguistic chains in the
caribbean and the running theme was the
song redemption song by bob marley man
to pick so i've used the lines
emancipate yourself for mental slavery
then i was just confirmed minds and that
was my main idea for my project so i'm
investigating uh why people in the
caribbean speak the way that they do
saint vincent is a very very special
country actually saint vincent is the
link between the
americans and the african born people
with the garifunas in belize you can
imagine saint vincent and the garifunas
in belize which which are belizeans no
they are lost paradise and vincent it's
not africa
no and if they call us queues
the the black are coming from the
caribbean because they are distinct they
are from saint wilson and they are
garifunas and they are the living
prisons of the
caribbean
of the caribs i'm sorry no and saint
vincent has some other
interesting
uh aspects also with regard to creole
when the british took over trinidad i
mean when the spaniards gave to me that
through
to the british and the british could not
put order into that because police
and the population speculated which is
always thought that the police and the
population were
the conifers
i'm conspiring conspiring against the
british so what they did
they
had a set of agents and been sentient
commerce policemen because they were
monolingually speaking so that held the
british nobody
that
is can be used as a tool for oh yes so
you said i mean and also now they feel
like is because the belgians and the
vicinian do not speak real no et cetera
does that give them an opportunity but
saint vincent is
very important for this
he also
the
the
co-presence of black caribbeans and red
carpets and this is in itself also a
very very very
important
they have a way of calling the caribbean
plantation america so what do we have to
do with plantation plantation is a
european institution you said i mean so
let's see the diversity within our
countries you see i mean and that's a
very very very diverse country so my
name is marilyn belonado i was born in
the dominican republic
um i've lived in new york for about 12
years now
and i think my main reason behind taking
this class is that like i have grown up
in a very dominican neighborhood very
dominican household so i had very like i
wouldn't say negative but more tolerant
ideas about haiti and i wasn't really
like that knowledgeable about haiti but
i wanted to learn more you know instead
of like
these indoctrinate myself from what i
had known before
um and because of that in this class
i've gotten the chance to like learn
more about dominican spanish like
through my own research but also um we
were able to read the farming of bones
by edushantika and i really like um
getting to interview the people around
me and seeing like what do you actually
know about the history between dr and
haiti because like i really knew
anything and like you know i just wanted
to like look more into that
um and just seeing like how much we
don't know and how much more work we
have to do is just so surprising to me
and yeah i think that's why we took this
class well as i was telling you before
we started no the dr in us
well
i still would say we are two wings of
the same bird even though this sentence
was used between cuba and in puerto rico
but that's a fact we live together we
are the
i think the only case of two countries
in the same islands if there are two
cases in the world we are one of them
now
but what is interesting is
what we how we have increased
the diversity of the caribbean where i
spent 10 years in trinidad working with
the u.n
and
my friends at the academy in the
academic community think of in term of
plantation america and they would see
free village societies and bush negroes
and counter plantation this is marginal
the
core of development is no no i mean if
you take that
line
no you have equality at the end of time
you will never reach no equal plantation
is that plantation is the capitalist
institution no economic institution
while
to to
face that institution we had created
other things like the bush societies
like the privilege system and the place
where you can see that in the deer
because when you see the deer this is
where columbus started
washing away all the old tiles and all
the prestige of pre-columbian what you
imagine for a colombian a a
civilization and then
he start a set of co-existence of
remnant of the spanish group the poor
spaniards who could not follow with the
contest towards cuba et cetera no then
the spanish blacks ladinos who were
enslaved in spain and came to the
dominican republic then a set of
enslaved imported from africa then a set
of winery from jamaica who went in the
service themselves in the
in santo domingo all these before even
the french took over in
in the western part of the country you
serving and this will give you a type of
society what is also very important and
interesting in the dominican republic is
that they have that spanish tradition of
the ejidus
he does a reform of communal
ownership of the land
which the american had and the spaniard
conserved it now and this gave a certain
freedom of the population an
element to negotiate the plantation
system
well and the deer
bring something back to the diversity of
the cayman the spaniard came back
you know i mean they
re-colonize the country not during long
but enough to do much harm and to
establish the white supremacists
not in not only in the country but in
the head of the of the illegality of
saint domingue and this
reconquer
will be done against the haitian
position which had abolished obviously
slavery etc etc a time when cuba and
and puerto rico
still have salute
no and one of the problem of the
spaniard is that they say you want to
enslave us no way
you said i mean
this is very very interesting and very
important it's not to such an extent
that
in the dear and in haiti
there are brothers and sisters there are
no problems but the two oligarchies
they are like cat and dogs
they they can't stand each other
but underneath they are very friendly
and they are making their money quietly
but you should hear them so they prepare
the population to hate each other
this is their job to make us fight he
said i think that you have a very good
position to observe the diversity of the
caribbean and the importance of the
non-plantation system even though you
are probably one of the best actual
system of plantation
actually there's a book called um why
the [ __ ] fights
yeah yeah so it's a book about the
history of the deer in haiti now that
you mentioned you know they make sure
that
they fight
oh yeah yeah
why because you know when you go to
these um
cog fighting the days
the humans are the ones making the cops
fight the cops don't want to fight right
the [ __ ] are not made to fight
so much you know so
it's such a powerful metaphor you know
that the deer and haiti why do they
fight well they fight basically like why
the [ __ ] fight because they have other
people pushing them to fight
yeah
yeah
hi i'm gabrielle with gabby
and i'm jamaican and i took this class
because i really don't know much about
my people's history with that so
anything that says like kirby and
culture lessons or something i was
always like interested in because um i
was raised by my mother
and although she has like fun stories
about like school life in jamaica and
stuff like that she never really told me
much about the history of jamaica
so i only knew like surface level stuff
and i wanted to go in more
and my project was on how
european nations to this day have some
type of economic
power in the caribbean despite them
trying to like form their own economic
power and how europe kind of
uses hegemony to build off that
um and i thought that was pretty
interesting
it is indeed
yes
no
i must say that the jamaica has probably
of the best historians of the guy brain
and yesterday i was privileged enough to
have dinner with one of them which is a
a vince brown vincent brown now who just
came out with a tremendous book you
certainly know over or read not a tucky
no i mean one of the best uh
stories of how the africans in
the guiban fought for themselves and
maintain themselves jamaica has this
peculiarity of having forced the british
not to recognize
this defense no and this is this is
to my mind very important
the how we have been able
to defend ourselves to keep our
[Music]
differences and to reproduce it so what
you have is that for instance one of the
reason why haiti was
a
independent no i mentioned the fact that
the british was going up but the other
reason is that when in 1804 and the
french was before in 1791 when the
french were in crisis
60 of the haitians came from africa was
african-born people you know in those
people
turkey
revolution is describing a set of people
coming straight from africa you said i
mean so this gives you an an idea
of the conservation of
an identity you have received in your
village
no and here
no the the the position you have against
the system that is and how you finding
that but
in in between what is important and this
is where the caribbean appeals now is
that you come from congo you come from
you are an ashanti you are a wall of you
are zulu you mean and with all are
coming to becoming jamaicans so the the
process of unification it is where we
are going to create a new identity which
is caribbean
while the to follow you
your the institution created by europe
want you to be
homogenized individuals without a
community without an identity proper so
you are supposed to be british for
instance
i was one day
of two my great friends both of them but
one of them is from the dr
yodan from saint lucia
and
very high level persons
and
the friend from the india
say oh
are we
a afro-latin i say beg your pardon
because in the english-speaking country
it's nearly an offense to tell somebody
the natural saxons
and she defined herself as a full artist
and i said well me i'm no afro latin
what are you then well i happen to be
kaiban caribbean and caribbean food
there's no afro saxon no afro-latin we
are caribbean in our diversity and this
is what makes makes us really peculiar
no and different from any other form of
blackness
you know i mean
no matter where you go well i will not
explain that because it's fascinating
yes yes indeed so so gabby so gabby made
it tip-top talking about technology and
pay luck so should we watch gabby's tick
tock together
okay so what is car com
car com shortened for the caribbean
community and common market is an
organization made up of the caribbean
and latin americas to promote economic
growth and integration with the rest of
the market
on their own website they describe
themselves as developing countries who
have connections to markets in both
north and south america
so their goal basically to be taken
seriously and get caribbean economies on
the market however their plan of
execution is essentially to sell
themselves to the ones who matter the
most in the game
european nations
their who we are statement on their
website kind of seems to confirm this as
they um describe their community as
multilingual and go on to include
english french and dutch as their main
languages
now the language portion of this is
really important because it is very
symbolic when it comes to colonizee and
colonizer relationships
in the caribbean for example most people
speak some sort of creole or patra
derived from a blend of indigenous and
african languages as well as the
language of their colonizer these
languages despite being common tongues
are often treated as lesser
and the most prevalent example of this
is haiti's relationship with the french
who surprise surprise has had a stake in
keeping haiti a francophone country
[Music]
haiti's government has had a history of
disregarding their mother tongue of
creole despite it being one of their two
national languages the second one take a
wild guess
um funnily enough roughly five to ten
percent of haitians can actually speak
french fluently and those are usually
the elite
considering the active push in schools
to speak french by literally only
teaching in french you can see why
schools in haiti aren't exactly thriving
and why they needed to join car com in
the first place
so haiti like the rest of carcom wants
better economic opportunities for their
country and their people
yet the french seem to be getting in the
way
as they have historically always done
so haiti needs out of the disparities
the french have put them in yet
french rely on francophone countries to
keep them relevant and in power
so what do they do
money
they throw money at the situation
and then declare that they know best
that's
wonderful
[Laughter]
hi um i'm viviane and
i'm in this class i'm from palestine and
i
have been over the last
um
decade and a half of my life working
with
peasant communities
in recovering
ourselves through recovering our seed
heritage
and so i'm very interested in
imagination and how our imagination can
help us
in the journey of liberation so for me
the caribbean
is such a rich place to
learn from
and to understand from
other people's experiences
uh that have a lot of similarities and
obviously a lot of uniqueness to it
uh how do we
find our power and our beauty uh in the
and how can our beauty as we uncover it
we've been told it's ugly how can we
really
um
accentuate our beauty if you were an
extract it again to regain power in
ourselves so
i find a lot
in the caribbean for me
and the beauty of it and the beauty of
also finding power
inside the wounds that we have
so that's why
thank you i will not comment on that
no no no no i mean this is very
important because in fact he
i think
the results of the work i have done in
the book where we have in front of us is
that our
soul wealth is our imagination
because
if you take the people coming from
africa
in the cabin we are the majority no we
came
like worms we had just nothing and we
were individuals
nickel naked individuals with no contact
nothing there doesn't exist an
individual in the world who is alone
i mean an individual is come from a
community
so the first thing we we built was a
community
but building a community was
exactly opposing
the power of the plantation system
no with what did we build the community
with our mind with our imagination to
give you only one example
the european
family is based on private property
no the definition and of an enslaved in
the code noah is
he or she who cannot possess anything
that does not belong to his master
so obviously we had nothing
no yet we create family
we find a way of bypassing
this element obviously our families will
be called non-family promiscuous or all
sort of things
they try to deface our the product of
our imagination and up to now
up to now
they cannot cope with our family system
no if there are two institutions produce
products of our imagination that are
a
difficulty
that
despised no is voodoo and family
and they are the less understood
institutions
all over the caribbean we call it chango
baches quality
[Music]
obiya no matter they don't even know
what they are talking about
no and family did not understand family
they don't our family
no for instance in haiti
family is supposed to be
a patriarchal material god knows what no
all sorts of names
they don't know what it is they just
don't know what it is because
let's see you know what happened just to
to finish this comment
two persons in any countryside of haiti
old people they go to church they get
married they have because they are
celebrating their 50 years of living
together this is when they get married
they don't get married to have the right
to go to bed with one another no no no
no after being to bed after having their
kids their grandkids the situation now
the whole village is going to
celebrate their marriage i mean you see
our conception
of wedding is not the western conception
of wedding how could we have that if not
imagining another institution working in
another setting creating a story this is
that wealth
that bothered them because we are
different and a friend of mine in a
not different but a professor
in the zoom of the catholic church said
listen what my problem is the following
if you are a people that is being
exploited by some big master you will
tend to look like the master
no so you can defend yourself that he's
saying that but you prepared from the
beginning you say no
so how did that happen you said i mean
obviously this is what i'm telling you
we will
uh
from the beginning we are not from this
line of thought
the problem is how we're going to
maintain that identity we had
no
well
the difference is that we could not
because we came like individuals
so we have to create another community
and this community is kaiban made
it is not from africa it is not from
europe it is local
you see i mean we create something in
difficult condition and we are still
there
we're not the
we do have problems i cannot prove
anybody there that haiti is not the
first country in the world put it that
way what's important like to say but
like some of the people said and by the
way great kaiba and men lloyd best say
this is the most developed country of
america
as far a lord versus concern as far as
imagination as well as self-confidence
as far as identity as far as fighting to
stay
you know i mean because we we could
disappear
or the nation has disappeared the time
does disappear
we could disappear creation probably
will disappear but the day we forget our
basic values it is the day when we
disappeared not before
i mean i will not speak of my friends
from palestine you know i mean they are
on the verge of and we are on the verge
of
you know i mean we're on the verge of
but we will disappear but you have in
the caribbean for instance in dominica
uh cave caller la cavedes engines the
town the cave of the indians where they
found together the bones of 200 indians
who killed themselves wow
yeah i mean with the manufactures
poison the person themselves because
they do not want and cannot live under
the spanish
the spaniards you know i mean in mexico
there is also a wonderful example of
like
la
el canon del sumidero el canon your
canyon sumidero is well well what
happened is that
this group of the first nation
is fighting against spaniards and the
spaniard army is coming and they just
cannot win no so they put the kids the
ladies and the warriors and they're
fighting and they all
locally
step back they retreat they retreated it
everybody fell into the canyon wow and
up to now you can visit mexico you will
visit the canyon del sudeiro i mean
certainly there has been genocide but
the point is that we have chose chosen a
collective suicide i mean this is how we
lived you said i mean we prefer to live
like that instead of
bending our head we have done that
already so okay we are fighting we are
poor we are weak but we ain't going to
be
too low ahead yeah and this is
i seek ibn because i'm talking about the
cabin but i'll give you an example of
mexico
you know i mean and i'm sure you'll find
that all over
mexico with the arrival of so one of the
point
points
that in fact he unites us here
and it is that
we have never thought
we were second to nobody
never never
and we cannot think that
you know
this is why we say
equality
no is the starting point it is not the
goal
yes i mean
we have to plan on the basis that we are
equal
so
i i mean we have in a
long tradition of contact with the
palestinians in fact the
the right arm of i see that somebody
damn
made peace he may hear us in peace his
name he's mary he was palestinian
no
and oh yes indeed no and
well
he was with us in the fight
and he died for that also
you know
so what's your project about can you
tell us about your project
my project yes for the class
uh which one
[Music]
and actually i'm
learning a lot about uh
voodoo in terms of a
spiritual practice but also finding a
lot of parallels
uh that i'm finding with
practices in palestinian
heritage that are
being we're being told are not uh
you know are not you know i'm not right
to think in that way like our
imagination in our spirituality whether
it's through
people who dream or people who um
relate to nature as also a source of
information uh through
also being taught by the catholic
schools and
all the
religious institutions that this is not
the way we should think and this is
primitive and we should throw it away
and so i'm interested so much in buddhi
because it's also another way of knowing
the world and being in the world that is
very liberatory
and i think there's so much wisdom there
that can
really improve our ability to live not
just in dignity but also with other
beings that we are equal to other beings
um and i feel like this is an urgent
learning for for today so i am in i've
interviewed
a priestess that uh
uh who is wonderful um and she's a great
storyteller so it also shows how like
telling stories and how stories are so
important
in in knowing ourselves like what is the
story we tell ourselves and the ability
to create a new story like
you know
um so
yes i am
exploring that also with myself and my
own dreaming
yes indeed
yes
thank you that was great so thanks to
all of you for sharing such personal
aspects of your
of yourselves um
so now it's it's one um so
technically we we're supposed to enter
the second part of of this which is um
you will
introduce say a few words about the
chapter 8 that we all read
then we go around the room and we each
ask
a question but i wonder whether it's a
good time for a break um before because
that might what do you think tom what do
you say
okay so they usually do yeah so let's
take a break um let's say it's uh it's
one so let's come back at 10 after one
it's 12 58 10 after one yeah and then
okay so get some coffee stretch your
legs and
you